[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAVNI DIWANJI: Hi, everyone.
I'm Pavni.
I am a VP of Engineering
here, leading Project Unicorn
on kids and families.
And I am just absolutely
thrilled to be here.
We have two very special guests
for Talks@Google, as you know.
We get a lot of amazing actors
and musicians and artists here,
but today I think is
very, very special,
as we have Ajay and Kajol.
They have been entertained us in
Bollywood for almost 25 years.
They have won numerous Filmfare
Awards and Padam Shris,
so I am absolutely
thrilled to have them here.
And they're going to be talking
to us about their new movie,
"Shivaay."
The movie's scheduled to
come out in Diwali time.
So please join me and
show your enthusiasm
in welcoming Ajay and Kajol.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE AND CHEERS]
AUDIENCE MEMBER: Hi, Kajol!
[LAUGHTER]
PAVNI DIWANJI:
Welcome to Google.
AJAY DEVGN: Thank you so much.
KAJOL: Thank you so much.
PAVNI DIWANJI: We are thrilled
to be here, and have you here.
As you can see, we have
several hundred Googlers here,
and watching us on live stream,
and then later we're also
going to be posting on YouTube.
And so we're-- the company's
excited to be hosting you.
KAJOL: Thank you, thank you.
PAVNI DIWANJI: And I am, too,
as you can tell. [LAUGHS]
So, I think my first
question, I was
going to lead with you, Ajay.
Is it your first
visit to the Bay Area,
to the tech capital
of the world?
AJAY DEVGN: Ah, no.
But I've come after years.
PAVNI DIWANJI: After years?
AJAY DEVGN: Yeah.
I mean, everything has
changed, so, technically, I
would say it's my first visit.
PAVNI DIWANJI: [LAUGHS]
How are you finding it?
AJAY DEVGN: I've
hardly seen anything.
I mean, it's fabulous.
But I've just entered.
And it's been just
like three hours.
We just went to--
KAJOL: We just landed, like we
landed in the morning, yeah,
this morning, so--
PAVNI DIWANJI: And I know you
stayed for a while in Bay Area
with "My Name Is Khan."
KAJOL: Yes, we did.
PAVNI DIWANJI: San Francisco,
and it was lovely to see--
KAJOL: I love San
Francisco, I have to say.
PAVNI DIWANJI: --the
city through your eyes.
KAJOL: Yes.
It's one of my favorite
cities in the world.
AUDIENCE: [CHEERING]
KAJOL: I love it.
Love it.
PAVNI DIWANJI: So what's
your favorite place?
People are asking.
Like, they want to go see
Kajol's favorite place.
KAJOL: [LAUGHS]
My favorite place?
I don't know.
Because I think
San Francisco's one
of those wonderful
combination cities.
It's just got the best of
Europe, America, and it's just,
it's so perfect.
I mean, you have the
most amazing houses.
You have the most amazing food.
AJAY DEVGN: It is [INAUDIBLE].
KAJOL: You're the
most amazing people.
Thank you so much
for all you guys.
AUDIENCE: [CHEERING]
KAJOL: [INAUDIBLE]
PAVNI DIWANJI: So,
as you might know,
YouTube is part of Google.
And you have a very, very
popular channel on YouTube.
And so we call-- we can, I
think, pretty much safely
call him a YouTuber.
What do you guys think?
Yeah.
So, and recently, I know you
released the wonderful trailer
of your film, "Shivaay," on it.
And I was looking,
and it quickly
got like 20 million views,
which is quite impressive.
So question for you is, how
has your YouTube journey
been so far?
AJAY DEVGN: It's been fabulous.
I think I was late entering
it, but now that I'm in,
it's fabulous.
And nowadays, most of
the time on YouTube.
PAVNI DIWANJI: So, you know,
we have some Google engineers,
and, I think, YouTube
engineers, too, watching.
And so, as I was saying,
if you have some wish list,
they might say make it.
You can say make it so to them,
and they might actually make--
AJAY DEVGN: OK.
So let me think of something,
and then I'll let you know.
PAVNI DIWANJI: Something
really difficult.
So, speaking of YouTube,
one of the things,
we heard a lot of questions, and
we can't accommodate everyone,
so we picked a few
questions on the video.
And speaking of videos, one of
the super-fans of yours, Kajol,
has submitted a video
question for you today.
She's like one of the
biggest fan, [? Re Re Lee. ?]
She's a Googler
in Mountain View.
And so we would love to roll
the video question, if we can.
[? RE RE LEE: Hi. ?] My name
is [? Re Re. ?] I'm a huge fan
of Kajol's because
of her movie, "DDLJ,"
which really got
me into Bollywood.
AUDIENCE: [CHEERING]
[? RE RE LEE: But I was ?]
wondering, for her,
what her thought process is when
she's deciding which project
and movie to be in?
Also, which of those is
her favorite, and why?
Thank you.
KAJOL: Ah, OK.
What is my thought process?
You know, I'm a big reader.
I love to read.
I've been one of those voracious
readers from the time-- I
think, my mother tells me,
from the time that I was two,
I was reading the
newspaper, the headlines
of the newspaper at that age.
So I love, love, love to read.
And when I listen
to a script, that's
really what I'm expecting
the script to be.
I'm expecting it to
be my favorite book.
And if it is, if it comes up
to that level, then I'm like,
OK, I'll do your film.
And if it doesn't, which most of
the time it doesn't, you know,
I'm like, ah, OK.
Not so great at
the end of the day.
So yeah.
That's really my first
and only criteria,
that it should be
an amazing book.
PAVNI DIWANJI: That's awesome.
That you go in with a completely
open mind, and read a book.
Awesome.
Going along, I think
we-- I understand
that you've been on a whirlwind
tour here for the movie.
And can you tell us a
little bit about the tour?
And also, how the
film came about?
AJAY DEVGN: This tour
has been very short.
I mean, day before yesterday,
we landed in New York.
Yesterday morning,
we were in Houston.
KAJOL: We were in Dallas.
AJAY DEVGN: We were
in Dallas and Chicago.
And I'll be here,
and leaving tonight.
I'm going back to India.
Because I have to
finish my film,
so I can't afford
staying for another day.
So this has been my
journey right now.
PAVNI DIWANJI: Yeah.
Tell us what brought it on.
How did you conceive
of the idea?
AJAY DEVGN: It was a basic
idea which inspired me,
because I would like to make
films which really touch
your heart, and this was
something-- not the story,
but the relationship.
It's about the
relationship I speak about,
which is very close to my heart.
And that's how the idea started.
And I had read an article
which really inspired me.
So we started working on it.
And that's how the
whole process started.
And once we got
the script right,
and then I really felt that I
need to take this film beyond,
because why do people have to
turn around and say that we
can't do this in our country?
We can't make films at par.
But I would say,
want to make better
than world cinema
or Hollywood films.
And that's how the
whole process started.
PAVNI DIWANJI: So it's like
a true made-in-India film.
AJAY DEVGN: I would say that.
I would say.
PAVNI DIWANJI: Wow.
Let's roll the
trailer, and then we
can talk a little
bit more about.
So folks, here is "Shivaay."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[PAPER CRUMPLING]
[SINGING]
[GUNSHOTS]
[BLADE SLICING]
[CAR TIRES SQUEALING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
AJAY DEVGN (VOICEOVER): [HINDI]
[HELICOPTER BLADES BEATING]
[SINGING]
AJAY DEVGN (VOICEOVER): [HINDI]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[SIRENS]
[HELICOPTER BLADES BEATING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
AJAY DEVGN (VOICEOVER): [HINDI]
[LAUGHTER]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
PAVNI DIWANJI: This
was incredibly magic.
AJAY DEVGN: Thank you so much.
PAVNI DIWANJI: I think
it's very impressive.
I was wondering, we are here
at Google, the heart of tech,
and maybe you can take
us through your journey
on how you actually managed
to make a film like this.
AJAY DEVGN: I think how, I
would like to tell you all
after I release the film first.
Because I should not
give out so many secrets.
But yes, we worked
very hard on it.
And our biggest
challenge, I would say,
was we have-- our country
has lovely technicians, so it
is not that we don't
have the talent.
I can see most of our
talent here, also.
So it is usually the
budgets which restrain us.
And more than that, I would
say, it's the planning.
And if you are
technically savvy,
you can execute a lot of things.
You do not need to
go mad and spend
like they do in
Hollywood, because we
can't afford that much.
But we can get that
kind of quality
if we apply our
mind right, and--
PAVNI DIWANJI: You
have to do it smartly.
AJAY DEVGN: Smartly,
and shoot it right.
PAVNI DIWANJI: Yeah.
And I think I was reading online
that you almost, like, you
saw a need, and the film needed
a certain type of camera.
And then, instead
of, like, nothing
was available, and you--
AJAY DEVGN: [INAUDIBLE] there
was some kind of equipment.
If you see the shots
which rotate all around,
and things like this, and that
kind of equipment, most of it
is not-- I mean,
we don't have it.
There are some equipment
which are not there at all.
So we designed it, I would
say, like Desi stuff,
but, you know, where we could
get our job done perfectly.
And yeah, so we all
worked very hard over it,
and we really figured out,
we designing the shots first,
because the most important thing
is how you design the shot.
And then, when I
did design the shot,
people said, OK, this
sounds very good,
but how are you
going to execute it?
And that was the challenge.
And then it just happened,
touch wood, very easily.
PAVNI DIWANJI: Kajol was
saying, behind the screen,
that you are a
tinkerer, and you like
to kind of make your own
things, and experiment, and--
AJAY DEVGN: [INAUDIBLE]
PAVNI DIWANJI: --not
take no for an answer.
And I also read, you--
KAJOL: [INAUDIBLE]
PAVNI DIWANJI: --kind
of drove the team
to quite off the edge, too.
Not just in the movie,
actor off the edge, so--
AJAY DEVGN: Yes.
In fact, my father is, and
was, the most respected action
director in our country, and--
KAJOL: He invented
so much, himself.
AJAY DEVGN: He invented so much.
KAJOL: As far as film
making was concerned--
AJAY DEVGN: When the effects
and CGI was not there.
I mean, he did films
like "Mr. India."
I don't know if you all
have seen a film called
"Mr. India," which was--
PAVNI DIWANJI: Yeah.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
AJAY DEVGN: And at that point
of time, it was all live.
So you couldn't cheat.
And he could manage
doing a lot of things.
And I was eight, nine years old.
And when I used to keep
discussing with him,
and he used to come and
tell me, I did this.
Tell me how.
And that's how the
whole process started.
By the age of 12, I
was editing with him.
And--
KAJOL: And editing,
at that point of time,
was not with a mouse.
So it was actually--
AJAY DEVGN: Oh,
it was actually--
KAJOL: --frame by frame.
AJAY DEVGN: A machine
called the Moviola.
So you had to hold the reel.
And you had to stand.
And there was a small monitor.
And you had to--
PAVNI DIWANJI: Wow.
KAJOL: Press the pedal.
AJAY DEVGN: Like
the accelerator.
We had to stand, and keep
rolling with our hands.
And, I mean, actually cut
the frame and join it.
KAJOL: Actually cut the
frame of the film print.
AJAY DEVGN: So it was a very
different process altogether.
So we've gone through all that.
And at that point of time, I
started making films myself,
also, and obviously,
I couldn't afford it,
so-- But I started
making my own equipments
at that point of time, where
I could take shots, which
so many people, at
that point of time,
he used to see those small
videos of mine, and say, OK.
I will go all my
father's friends, saying,
can I use this shot in a film?
I'm going to copy you.
Said, go ahead.
So it was like this.
That is the whole process.
So I think, because of my
father, I learned a lot.
And I tried to create things
which were not possible, also.
PAVNI DIWANJI: Yeah, I mean,
it shows in the trailer--
AJAY DEVGN: And
nowadays, it's become--
PAVNI DIWANJI: --how different--
AJAY DEVGN: --a lot
more easier, also,
with the effects, and
lots of things coming in.
But at that point of
time, there was nothing.
PAVNI DIWANJI: How
different it is.
I feel like you are going
to single-handedly raise
the bar on Bollywood.
AJAY DEVGN: Not single-handedly.
PAVNI DIWANJI: [INAUDIBLE]
AJAY DEVGN: I think
the whole team--
PAVNI DIWANJI: Team.
Team.
Yeah.
AJAY DEVGN: --very big effort.
PAVNI DIWANJI: I
think the thing that
struck me here was, it's
quite an action-packed film.
AJAY DEVGN: Honestly,
it's an emotional drama.
But if you notice the
action part of it,
also, it's not just
for the sake of it.
And there is pain on
the face, on my face,
also, and the other actors,
also, who are doing action
at that point of time.
So it's actually a very
real kind of thing.
PAVNI DIWANJI: Wow.
One of the things I was
talking in the hallway,
and someone mentioned
that you have always
been at the forefront
of this action drama.
Like Arnold Schwarzenegger come
to mind, for Bollywood, right?
Would you guys agree?
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
PAVNI DIWANJI: And I also--
KAJOL: Better accent, though.
PAVNI DIWANJI: [LAUGHS] And
I read that, a lot of times,
you like even doing
the stunts yourself,
and to figure out how
these stunts are done.
So you are not just like
tough guy on the screen,
but you're actually
trying to live it.
AJAY DEVGN: Actually,
that is by default,
because when I started
acting, my first film came in.
As I told you, I am an
action director's son.
So they expected me to
do the action myself.
They did not-- they
thought-- I mean,
he would not need a duplicate.
And I was practiced
for it, because
of my father and his
whole team and everything.
So, actually, it was by
default. So I was pushed into it
that, you know, you're
an action director's son,
so you have to do
your action yourself.
PAVNI DIWANJI: [LAUGHS] Well,
great results, we have to say.
[INAUDIBLE]
AJAY DEVGN: And then
I started enjoying it.
And now--
PAVNI DIWANJI: "Shivaay,"
"Singham," I mean,
there's so-- there's a whole--
AJAY DEVGN: Yeah.
And now it's been 25
years in the industry,
so when I started, I was 19.
I'm like 47 now.
And now I like
doing my own stunts,
trying to prove a point--
what the duplicates can do,
I can do.
So [INAUDIBLE] gives me
some kind of satisfaction.
PAVNI DIWANJI: So much
for showing the way.
Great.
I think it's great.
I think the Google team wanted
to know what's next for you.
What's the next big challenge?
Are we going to see you guys
in some romantic role, maybe?
What's coming next?
Give us something
that we can't--
AJAY DEVGN: I'm starting
a film on our production.
We're starting a film with her,
which is a fabulous script,
and she's loved a lot.
Like she just said
that she takes her time
to choose a script, so--
PAVNI DIWANJI: Yeah.
So we'll actually be
able to see both of you?
AJAY DEVGN: No, I won't
be in that film because--
KAJOL: I tried to make him
do a cameo, or a passing
shot, or something like that.
PAVNI DIWANJI: Yeah.
I think he should, right?
Clap your hands, or stomp your
feet, if you want [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE AND CHEERS]
AUDIENCE MEMBER: [INAUDIBLE]
KAJOL: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
KAJOL: See?
AJAY DEVGN: Yeah.
That's not a bad idea.
KAJOL: I've been telling him.
He told me, I got
married to you.
That was enough.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
PAVNI DIWANJI: I read
somewhere that you never
left home without your sense
of humor, and it shows, right?
So we've heard from
some global fan,
but you also have a
huge fan following
in India, of course, and
also in Google in India.
And so our next question is
going to come from a Googler
all the way in Hyderabad.
KAJOL: Wow.
PAVNI DIWANJI: So could we
please roll the question?
[? SHUP: Hello, ?] Ajay sir.
Hello, Kajol ma'am.
I am [? Shup, ?] and
I'm from Hyderabad.
It's really a real
pleasure for me
to get this opportunity
to ask you a question.
And I have been a very
big fan of both of you,
you know, since a long
time, ever since the "Pyaar
To Hona Hi Tha" days.
So today, the question I'm
going to ask is for both of you.
And the question is, you have
both been in the industry
for a very, very long time.
And during this time, there
has been a sea of changes.
My question to both of you today
is, as established superstars,
what do you both do to
keep up with these changes?
Thank you.
AJAY DEVGN: Honestly?
KAJOL: Very little.
AJAY DEVGN: No.
In fact, we learn a
lot from our kids.
KAJOL: Yeah.
AJAY DEVGN: And their friends,
and the new generation.
I think it's very,
very important.
I don't even know how to
be on the net properly.
I mean, whatever I learn
is from my daughter.
And when I ask her a question,
and she does something,
I say, how did you do it?
She says, don't ask me,
you old [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
AJAY DEVGN: So that's
the answer we get.
They can do anything.
So I think it's great.
PAVNI DIWANJI: We can relate.
I can relate, too.
AJAY DEVGN: Of course.
And it's great.
And it's great you have
to learn from them.
PAVNI DIWANJI:
That's the future.
AJAY DEVGN: That's how you
keep upgrading yourself.
PAVNI DIWANJI: That's
great. [INAUDIBLE]
I think Kajol was
telling us, at the back,
was that she's a
big Android fan.
Can you believe it?
AUDIENCE: [CHEERING]
PAVNI DIWANJI:
And she frequently
has debates in the house,
because the kids like iPhones,
and she loves Android.
So we are thrilled to hear that.
So this is a question.
The next question is
related to the change.
And we at Google are very
passionate about women's
involvement.
And I know both of you are.
And I just saw the
"Parched" movie trailer
that you released on YouTube.
And it kind of moved me.
It promises to-- I haven't
watched the full movie yet,
and I'm really, really
looking forward to it.
And a question first, for
you, Kajol, on the topic,
is, it seems from
outside of Bollywood
that the change is coming
slowly, in terms of respect,
and female actress
respect in Bollywood.
KAJOL: It is.
Definitely.
And I think that's because,
like I said earlier on,
that's because the
audience has changed.
Not for any other reason.
But, you know, when people start
turning around and spending
money to go and watch a film,
which is not in the quote,
unquote, "regular"
stream of films,
or regular kind
of genre, I think
that's when that change
actually happens.
And right now,
actually, I think it's
an amazing time in
the film industry,
because we have so many
different kinds of films
being made.
And it is now economically
feasible for them to be made.
Because people are going
outside, watching them,
enjoying them.
Social media has a lot to do
with it, because they go out
and they talk about it
on every media platform
that they can find.
And I think that, in
itself, makes it huge.
That, you know, you don't have
that herd mentality anymore,
to say that, you know,
if one person-- You know,
nobody is making
money on this film,
because one person has
not liked the film.
You have 100 different opinions.
Everybody has their opinion.
And everybody can go out and
say that, I like this film.
Let me go and watch
it, and let me
take my 30, 40 friends with me.
So, yeah.
PAVNI DIWANJI: Yeah.
As I was watching the trailer
for "Parched," I was moved,
and, like, OK, this
is a story that we
should have told a while ago.
And I'm really
glad that someone--
AJAY DEVGN: And the best part
is, the film is based in India.
But, I mean, it's gone
all over the world.
It's gone to 28--
KAJOL: Film festivals.
AJAY DEVGN: 28 film festivals.
It's won 18 awards.
And people, women,
people all over the world
connect with this film.
Some way or the other--
KAJOL: From every
kind of strata--
AJAY DEVGN: --they feel that--
KAJOL: Doesn't matter.
AJAY DEVGN: --it is their film.
So I think the
situation for women
is the same all over the world.
I mean, it must be different--
KAJOL: Women feel the
same all over the world.
I think--
AJAY DEVGN: [INAUDIBLE]
KAJOL: And they're put in
the same kind of situations.
AJAY DEVGN: --same
issues also, yeah.
PAVNI DIWANJI: I
think it's so great
to see both of you championing
these really, really
important social causes.
AJAY DEVGN: We try
to balance it well,
because the field we
are in, entertainment,
it cannot just be about
social causes, also,
because people expect you to
make films which entertain them
in whatever format--
not just comedy,
but any which way
which touches them.
So we need to strike a balance.
And that's what we try to do.
PAVNI DIWANJI: Yeah.
It's pretty awesome.
If you guys haven't watched
it, I was quite moved.
KAJOL: I want to just say
one thing about "Parched"
that-- It's one of those films.
Sorry.
I'm just going to
just put it out there.
But "Parched" is one of those
things that is not preachy.
That is not trying to
teach you anything.
It's not giving you a lesson.
It's literally like
a slice of life.
It could be your life.
It could be my life.
It could be your best
friend's life with you.
So it's that kind of a film.
And there is something.
The message behind "Parched"
is absolutely wonderful,
because the message
behind "Parched"
is that women's empowerment
starts with women.
It starts with every woman
standing up for herself.
You may need a helping
hand sometimes,
but it starts with
you, inside yourself.
That power within you,
you have to access.
And that's what "Parched"--
PAVNI DIWANJI: Well said.
Well said.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
AJAY DEVGN: Somebody just
said that I've seen it.
AUDIENCE MEMBER: I
felt-- As a woman,
I felt this is what
I was waiting for.
KAJOL: Awesome.
AUDIENCE: And I felt so proud.
There is someone out there for
us, who is thinking about it,
and is making such
movies. [INAUDIBLE]
AJAY DEVGN: I hope the
director of the film
is listening to this,
and this is for her.
PAVNI DIWANJI: So I'm going
to shift gears a little bit,
and go from reel to real life.
And I'll start with you, Kajol.
You have played
multiple roles, right?
Daughter, girlfriend,
wife, mother--
KAJOL: Girlfriend
was too long back.
PAVNI DIWANJI: Which
do you find most
challenging and satisfying,
both in the reel and the real?
KAJOL: You know, my husband
told me this amazing line.
He's like, you know, women,
from the time they are kids,
have played multiple roles, are
taught to play multiple roles.
That's why we're so
good at multitasking.
So we're natural multi-taskers,
because we're sisters.
We're daughters.
We're children.
We grew up, and we become
girlfriends, wives.
AJAY DEVGN: What I meant
was, women, their roles
keep changing.
You know?
They start from daughters,
sisters, girlfriends, wives,
mothers.
They keep evolving.
Men don't.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHING]
AJAY DEVGN: Which is a fact.
A man is always a man.
And we're born to be a man.
Till he dies.
And even when we
talk about "Parched,"
it's just not about women.
It's about the pressure
of society on men
to do certain kind of things--
KAJOL: And to remain
in a certain groove.
AJAY DEVGN: --to show
that they are men.
But you don't need to
prove that you're a man.
You don't need to prove it.
KAJOL: You don't
need to do whatever
they say that you need to do
to prove that you're a man.
AJAY DEVGN: So I think
women evolve faster,
and that's why they grow
better, and men get stuck.
I really read this, also,
that-- maybe it was mythology
or what-- that in
the olden times,
man was supposed to
[? ask ?] to-- I mean,
Hindus, maybe, takes [INAUDIBLE]
or just leave the family
and go away after
the age of 40, 45,
because it is the same thing
that a man couldn't change.
He always wanted
to rule the house.
He wanted the power.
And obviously, it's the
same lion mentality.
You know, when the
other one has come,
one has to leave the jungle.
PAVNI DIWANJI: I think it's
really great to see you
guys have such a great rapport
and partnership of views,
as well.
This really brings me
to the next question,
which is one of our
other video questions,
from fans Michelle
and Monica, who
want to learn about your
secrets of what we call here
work-life balance, if
there is such a thing.
So could we roll the
video question, please?
MICHAEL: Hi.
I'm Michael.
MONICA: And I'm Monica.
And we're super
big fans of yours.
And we were curious-- as
a high-profile couple,
how do you balance being a
couple with your careers?
AJAY DEVGN: Going to answer?
KAJOL: I will.
No need to ask me that question.
You have to stop me and
put a muzzle on my mouth
most of the time.
But I think this is something
that a lot of people ask us,
the how do you balance?
How do you make that?
How do you make it work?
How do you make it OK every day?
And I just have one
answer for that,
because you have to
work at it every day.
You can't decide that, OK, today
I'm taking a holiday from work.
That's not going to happen.
It's a relationship.
It is your life, at
the end of the day.
It's your kids, your husband.
And whatever they are, they are.
I mean, they are
my life, for sure.
I don't know about
everybody else.
But, yeah, they are my life.
And when I'm talking
about, when I'm
talking about balancing your
personal work and your family
life together, it's a work
in progress every day.
You put in that effort.
You put in that little
extra every day.
And you have to put in a little
bit of extra for yourself,
as well.
I mean, there's no
two ways about it.
If you don't put in that
little extra for yourself,
you will feel shortchanged.
And that's where all
the guilt starts.
And that's where all those
horrible cycles start,
where we don't want
to, you know, oh, god.
I'm feeling martyred.
And, oh, god, why I'm doing
all this and nobody else
is helping me out, and all that.
So I think, I honestly
believe, that everybody has
to-- Every day is a new day.
Every day.
Some days, I'm a good mother.
Some days, I'm
not a good mother.
Some days I'm a better wife.
Some days I'm a better actor.
Some days I'm a
better multitasker.
Some days I don't
finish my checklist
that I wake up with
in the morning.
So I think, forgive yourself
for whatever you're doing.
We women are conditioned
to carry so much guilt
from the time that
we're born, really.
I think we need to learn how
to forgive ourselves, and teach
our children that.
PAVNI DIWANJI: Great.
Hear, hear.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
PAVNI DIWANJI: So I know
you have two lovely kids.
And Nassa--
KAJOL: I do.
AJAY DEVGN: Nysa.
KAJOL: Nysa.
PAVNI DIWANJI: Nysa.
And you both come from a long
lineage of film families,
and acting and directing,
and action, is in your blood.
And we are curious.
Do you coax them to follow
your footsteps into, and join
the industry?
Do you take them to work?
How do you approach--
KAJOL: No, we don't.
We don't do that.
AJAY DEVGN: They're
too small, as yet.
My daughter's just--
KAJOL: 13.
AJAY DEVGN: 13.
KAJOL: Though she
looks very [INAUDIBLE].
AJAY DEVGN: Now she's
started teaching us.
But my son's too small, as yet.
So it's--
KAJOL: And I think
it depends, also--
AJAY DEVGN: [INAUDIBLE]
KAJOL: I mean, it's like
what makes her happy.
And we'd rather, as two
people who have so much
of the limelight on us, keep
the limelight away from them,
so that they grow up to have
a personality of their own,
have dreams and
aspirations of their own,
which are maybe somewhat
connected to us,
but not connected to
who and what we are.
PAVNI DIWANJI: I
think you're right.
Early on, you want
to shield them,
so that they can
develop on their own,
and develop their own.
So, talking about limelight, one
of the questions that came up
is, none of us know the fame
and recognition that both of you
do.
And I know it must
impact your daily lives.
And so, one of the
questions that came up
is, how do you live
in this bubble?
If you want to go to
Chowpatty and have pani puri,
or go to the [INAUDIBLE], or--
KAJOL: See?
Now you have convinced me.
I'm taking my shoes off.
Very uncomfortable.
I've got Band-Aids on my feet.
I'm just taking them off now.
And I'm going to stand
on my tippy toes,
and nobody's supposed
to comment on my height.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
PAVNI DIWANJI: I said to her
before, and it will be fine.
This is Google.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
PAVNI DIWANJI: But do
you have to work at just
making your lives regular.
in some--
AJAY DEVGN: It's-- actually,
it's been quite a few years
now.
I mean, we did have
issues earlier.
But I think it becomes
a part of your life now.
KAJOL: And I think the kids
have also gotten used to it.
We were very worried
at one point,
because when the
kids were younger,
it was like they
were really small,
and when you're entering an
airport or something like that,
and you have 30, 40 people
trying to grab on to you,
or click pictures, or
screaming and shouting.
And, you know, my daughter--
And they're kids.
They're small.
And they feel like,
oh my God, you know,
somebody's attacking
you, or somebody's
trying to get on you, and you're
trying to control the kids,
and you're trying
to manage the media.
And it was-- when
they were younger,
it was a bit of a mess.
But I think now, now that
they've grown up a little bit,
they've gotten used to it.
We've gotten used to it.
So, yeah, we're better now.
PAVNI DIWANJI: OK.
Awesome.
So I have one last
question for both of you,
and it goes back to you two make
such a magical pair off-screen,
and Googlers, one of the top
requests from the Googlers
is, they would like to see
you on screen together.
So when can we expect to see
you guys together on screen?
AJAY DEVGN: Hopefully, when
we get the right script.
I think--
PAVNI DIWANJI: Ah!
The right book.
AJAY DEVGN: Yeah.
We both are quite fussy.
And if we work
together, I think it
should be something fabulous,
and we both should like--
KAJOL: Which justifies both
of us, and where we are,
and who we are today.
AJAY DEVGN: Like the film
she's doing right now,
which we'll start-- there's no
character for the-- If I have
to play any character in the
film, it'll be her son, so--
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
PAVNI DIWANJI: I think the sense
of humor runs in the family.
KAJOL: At my cost.
PAVNI DIWANJI: So I wanted
to say a huge thank you
to both of you for coming here.
KAJOL: Thank you.
AJAY DEVGN: Thank you.
PAVNI DIWANJI: We really
enjoyed this conversation.
And you have an amazing
movie coming up in "Shivaay."
And we look forward
to watching it.
KAJOL: It's releasing on the
20th of October, in case you
guys, nobody knows about it.
Which I'm sure you'll
already know, but--
PAVNI DIWANJI: So,
folks, please give them
a big, big round of applause.
KAJOL: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
AJAY DEVGN: Thank you so much.
It was lovely being here.
KAJOL: Thank you.
PAVNI DIWANJI: Thank you.